to this authors historians and folks
that other folks that use oral history
in innovative ways tonight we have a
program about activism which is
appropriate on this election day
entitled United in anger historicizing
act up and we're going to hear from um
Jim Hubbard
and Sarah Schulman and if you'll just
give me a moment here to introduce both
Jim and Sarah Jim Hobart has been making
films since 1974 including elegy in the
streets to marches the dance and memento
mori his films have been shown at the
Berlin Film Festival London Film
Festival the San Francisco Film Festival
and many other lesbian and gay film
festivals his film memento mori won the
ursula for Best Short Film at the
Hamburg lesbian and gay Film Festival in
1995 in 1987 Jim and Sarah Schulman
co-founded mix at the New York lesbian
and gay experimental film video festival
and deaths a mere act up again was
founded with Jim and Sarah together
Jim is now the president of a of the mix
actually I'm not the president
no president is sitting behind I'm only
I've been demoted to treasurer
thank you I'm gonna continue with this
is a very brief synopsis of Jim and
Sarah's many many accomplishments so
bear with me um under the auspices of
the estate project for artists with AIDS
Jim created the Royal s Marc's eggs
after this video collection at the New
York Public Library he curated the
series fever in the archive AIDS
activist videotapes from the royal s
Marx collection for the Guggenheim
Museum in New York and again Jim has
many many accomplishments but we're
going to move to Sarah who co-founded in
1987 act up with Jim is you know we did
not know oh no okay okay I strike that
yeah Sarah is widely published many many
places too many to name but I'll just a
few of the New York Times the nation
Village Voice and The Guardian has won a
Guggenheim Award is the author of 15
published or soon to be published works
for nonfiction books a play and nine
novels translated into eight languages
filmmaker professor of English at the
City University of New York as she
mentioned earlier a fellow at the New
York Institute for Humanities at NYU on
the advisory collective of the human
rights and social movements program at
Harvard's Kennedy Center and in
recognition to her contributions to the
communities Sarah was made a resident
fellow for the future of New York City
here at Columbia and Sarah's doing some
interesting work in Palestine in the
coming year so please welcome Jim and
thank you
so I knew I think we're going to start
by each of us telling our different
stories about our own history with the
AIDS crisis and how we came to this I'm
going to start I was a City Hall
reporter for the New York native the New
York native was the gay newspaper in New
York and at that time Koch the evil Ed
Koch was mayor and we were trying to get
a gay rights bill passed so at that time
you could be kicked out of a restaurant
you could be denied a job you could be
denied an apartment you'd be kicked out
of a hotel if you were gay
in fact I personally was kicked out of
Kenny's castaways on Bleecker Street
because I was on a date with a woman and
we were kissing and then waitress came
over and said I'm really sorry but
you're gonna have to leave and we had to
leave so that was the situation and
people were trying to get a gay rights
though which did finally get passed in
1986 but anyway so I would go down to
City Hall say Sarah Schulman from the
New York native mayor Koch when are we
going to pass the gay rights bill so I
was 23 1981 aids was first noticed AIDS
of course has existed for decades before
1981 and in fact in a number of our
interviews particularly people who work
with the homeless and with IV drug users
there was two phenomena one called
junkie pneumonia which is basically PCP
and the other called the dropsies I
think
which was wasting syndrome that were
totally identified and recognized within
drug user communities way before aids
was identified but it was only when aids
was became visible in the white gay male
community that science acknowledged that
it existed or recognized it and for
those of you who don't know originally
was identified as a gay cancer
Kaposi's sarcoma and it was a thought
that it was connected to homosexuality
somehow inherently in fact lesbians were
not allowed to give blood at the
beginning of the AIDS crisis because I
thought it would have to do with
homosexuality so no one knew how it was
transmitted away so was Charlie by an
accident of history that I happened to
be on the scene as a girl reporter when
AIDS started and I covered a lot of
early stories that covered the closing
of the bathhouses
for the New York native the forming of
the first PWA organizations I then went
on and became an AIDS reporter at the
Village Voice they were the first piece
of women being excluded from
experimental drug trial they were the
first piece on homeless people with AIDS
that appeared anywhere which was in the
nation
it was interesting as a nation was so
homophobic that the only way they would
cover AIDS was when it affected homeless
people and that's you know it's a one
hand you know people who ignore homeless
people with AIDS at any of people for
whom it's more acceptable than gay
people at that time and I also covered
pediatric AIDS which fortunately doesn't
exist anymore for reasons that we'll go
into later which it has to do is
important part of the history of act-up
but at the time there was a lot of
pediatric AIDS and
and the infants were being treated on
placebo basis and this raised the issue
of consent what is consent which has
been a question that has pervaded
throughout the AIDS crisis and it's
still very present today especially in
vaccine research which is not conducted
in the United States because we have
more rigid consent standards so so I was
on this from the very early days and the
first five years of AIDS there were
40,000 people died of AIDS from 81 to 85
there were no treatments the only
treatment was a recycled failed cancer
drug called azg that cost ten thousand
dollars a year and ultimately didn't
work but people didn't realize that and
then active was founded in 1987 and I
jumped out in February I joined in July
so that's how I got to act that my
relationship to AIDS and to act up is
much like my relationship to the world
and that's through the lens of a camera
I'm in FileMaker and the world
and literally look at the world and I
started filming the gate movement in the
late 70s and when when I first became
aware of AIDS in 1981 and in those few
years first few years I wanted to make a
film about it but it was I couldn't
figure out how to do it it was really
difficult in the mainstream media if
they weren't ignoring people with AIDS
they were showing them as you know these
horrible shameful victims of this
disgusting disease and you know I wasn't
gonna about to recreate that on some
grassroots level I wanted to do
something different right
I kind of found it around looking for a
subject I met this guy and who had AIDS
and I started filming him because he
didn't want me in space with a camera
all the time so that didn't succeed and
then two things happen one is my
ex-lover Roger Jacobi was diagnosed with
AIDS in August of 1984 and from then
until his death in November of 1985 I
filmed him because he was a filmmaker he
was used to having a camera around and
also he wanted to be and then when he
died I inherited all his outtakes so I
and he was something of a narcissist so
he filmed himself a lot so so I had had
that and then then suddenly in in March
of 1987 act-up appeared and there was
something that was really exciting to
film all of a sudden
so because act up with really conscious
of media and wanting
to do something that was visually
interesting in order to get people's
attention so so I have those two things
I had a personal relationship to two
aides and the political relationship to
aides and I combined them in a film
which eventually it was finished in 1989
is called elegy in the streets and it's
a 30 minute silent self processed
experimental film about about those
things the personal and political
experiences and reactions to to eighties
and so I I first filmed act up in June
of 1987 at the lesbian gay pride march
that year they had a concentration camp
because people were really afraid that
the Reagan administration was gonna put
quarantine people with AIDS and then the
next thing I filmed was the 96 our
continuous picket of Memorial
sloan-kettering hospital there were a
group of five to seven hospitals I
including Columbia Presbyterian that
were designated as each treatment
evaluation units a teus and these
hospitals were supposed to do trials on
drugs and I don't remember the exact
numbers but say sloan-kettering this was
to get a hundred and twenty people
enrolled in a trial and you know after a
year and spending all sorts of money
they had eight people so active spent
ninety six hours embarrassing them in
the mail
they that they get to work and then from
that on I you know I don't act ups
demonstrations and when I say filmed I
mean film I mostly on 16 millimeter
although at that time the Rosa movement
the exact this video movement where
forty sixty out it and we don't know how
many people who had access to consumer
grade video cameras video aid camp came
out in 1988-89 so suddenly middle class
people could afford video cameras and
relatively high quality ones so so there
was a movement to document what wasn't
being documented by the mainstream media
and and to create videotapes that could
be sent around the country as VHS tapes
and get the vital information that could
help people and now also at that time in
1988 I got a grant which consisted of a
video 8 camera this is my first video
camera and I said I was going to do oral
histories of act up I proceeded to do I
did seven of them it was ten and a half
hours of footage and the filmmaker of me
who was used to dealing with two minute
and 46 seconds reels of 16 millimeter
film looked at 10 and a half hours of
footage and said oh my god what am I
going to do with this how am I ever
going to edit it and I stopped doing it
and so the act of oral history project
is at least in part a corrective for
that misunderstanding of the value of
okay so let me just tell you a little
bit about how we started this project so
joined act up that that that was my
first action sloan-kettering 1987 so he
remember at that point there were no
treatments by 1996 the cocktail we call
a cocktail was a combination treatments
were all we're now in place so within 10
years act up completely revolutionized
treatments and forced through a lot of
research and treatments became available
that's within quotation marks if you are
healthy if you have insurance if you
have a home you can get treatment if you
can tolerate the treatment and you're
hiv-positive you can live a full life in
the United States that's a lot of it but
that's basically what was achieved by
1996 at that point active had to
basically de mobilized for a lot of
reasons which we can go into later and
we all went on with our lives cut ahead
it's 2001 I'm in LA I'm driving it
around in a little white rental car I'm
listening to NPR and they're saying
today is the 20th anniversary of AIDS
that's interesting and then the the
announcer says at first America had
trouble with people with AIDS but then
they came around like I almost crashed
the car and I pulled over I remember I
had my first cell phone so we decided
that we're going to start this project
and we began interviewing people that we
had no
and the interviews are long-form they're
two to four hours each no one has ever
cut short people can talk for as long as
they wish I've conducted all the two
interviews Jim and southern guy James
Wednesday or the camera guys so
basically if a little mom-and-pop
project and because it's the two of us
we have been able to consistently
conceptualize the project I do not
understand how an outsider can conduct
oral histories to tell you the truth and
I don't understand how questions can
drive a moral history project both of
those things are mysterious to me
because every time to talk to somebody
we're finding out new information
we're rican sexualizing the
understanding of the movement how it
functioned and I always and I just want
to tell you two things that we've I
think we've come to understand from from
this process of changing questions one
is that how how ACTA worked that the
reason it was successful because was
that there was a simultaneity of actions
that all the kinds of people were
working on all different kinds of levels
based on where they were at and just as
a very experienced political organizer
let me tell you people can only be where
they're at so if you try to have a
movement where you're controlling
everyone and telling them that they
can't do and what they can do what they
must do where they must go it's probably
not going to work but the thing about
act-up was a true democracy and
everybody was doing what they needed to
do so if you needed to work with the
black church you work with the black
church if you need to go to Chinatown
he worked in Chinatown if you needed to
work on needle exchange that's what you
did people and because they was
self-selected and it was going on
simultaneously
that's how act-up was able to create
change because it was never a huge
number of people the largest
demonstration they ever had was 7,000
people surrounding Saint Patrick's
Cathedral but for the most part it was
between like 4 and 800 people it was one
of those vanguard organizations where
people were very very focused they had
very fixed agendas
they and they move towards those agendas
so that was the first thing one of the
first things that we learned and the
second thing we learned is that it was
the opposite of Occupy Wall Street in
that act of had very specific demands
and the way it was constructed was very
set if you read dr. King's letter from
Birmingham jail he lays out a strategy
very similar to act us although we were
not aware of that we came to the same
conclusions first he calls self
education so active became their experts
on aids to the point where act up was
telling science what needed to be
researched they were telling was saying
what laws needed to be passed what
insurance policies needed to be passed
we were setting an agenda for everything
that needed to change we were the
experts in every arena we would develop
the plan of how to get drugs to people
who couldn't afford them and present
those plans to the FDA and we did all
the conceptualization then we would
present a mega demand that was reason
and that was reasonable and doable not
something that was impossible for
example ACT UP went to the Food and Drug
Administration the vests authors
historians and folks that other folks
that use oral history in innovative ways
on tonight we have a program about
activism which is appropriate on this
election day entitled United in anger
historicizing act up and we're going to
hear from Jim Hubbard and Sarah Schulman
and if you'll just give me a moment here
to introduce both Jim and Sarah Jim
Hobart has been making films since 1974
including elegy in the streets to
Marge's the dance and memento mori his
films have been shown at the Berlin Film
Festival London Film Festival the San
Francisco Film Festival and many other
lesbian and gay film festivals his film
memento mori' won the ursula for best
short film at the Hamburg
lesbian and gay Film Festival in 1990
five in 1987 Jim and Sarah Schulman
co-founded mix the New York lesbian and
gay experimental film video festival and
that same year act up again was founded
with Jim and Sarah together
Jim is now the president of a of the mix
actually I'm not the president no
president I'm only I've been demoted to
treasurer I'm going to continue with
this this is a very brief synopsis of
Jim and Sarah's many many
accomplishments so bear with me um under
the auspices of the estate project for
artists with AIDS
Jim created the Royal s Marx eggs
activist video collection at the New
York Public Library he curated the
series fever in the archive AIDS
activist videotapes from the royal s
Marx collection for the Guggenheim
Museum in New York
and again Jim has many many
accomplishments but we're going to move
to Sarah who co-founded in 1987 act up
with Jim is you know we did not know Oh
No okay okay I strike that yeah Sarah is
widely published many many places too
many to name but I'll just a few of the
New York Times the nation Village Voice
and The Guardian has won a Guggenheim
Award is the author of 15 published or
soon to be published works for
nonfiction books a play and nine novels
translated into eight languages no maker
professor of English at the City
University of New York as you mentioned
earlier a fellow at the New York
Institute for Humanities at NYU on the
advisory collective of the human rights
and social movements program at
Harvard's Kennedy Center
and in recognition to her contributions
to the communities Sarah was made a
reticent fellow
for the future of New York City here at
Columbia and Sarah's doing some
interesting work in Palestine in the
coming years so please welcome Jim thank
you so I know I think we're going to
start by each of us telling our
different stories about our own history
with the AIDS crisis and how he came to
this so I'm gonna start I was a City
Hall reporter for the New York native
the New York native us to gain newspaper
in New York and at that time watch the
evil Ed Koch was mayor and we were
trying to get a gay rights bill fast so
at that time you could be kicked out of
a restaurant you could be denied a job
you could be denied an apartment you'd
be kicked out of a hotel if you were gay
in fact I personally was kicked out of
Kenny's castaways on Bleecker Street
because I was on a date with a woman and
we were kissing and then waiters came
over and said I'm really sorry but
you're gonna have to leave and we had to
leave so that was a situation and people
were trying to get it gay rights bill
which did finally get passed in 1986 but
anyway so I would go down to City Hall
say Sarah Schulman from the New York
native mayor Koch when are we going to
pass the gay rights bill so I was 23
1981 aids was first noticed AIDS of
course has existed for decades before
1981 and in fact in a number of our
interviews particularly people who work
with the homeless and with
IV drug users there was two phenomena
one called
junkie pneumonia which was basically PCP
and the other called the dropsies I
think which was wasting syndrome that
were totally identified and recognized
within drug user communities way before
AIDS was identified but it was only when
AIDS was became visible in the white gay
male community that science acknowledged
that it existed or recognized it and for
those of you who don't know originally
was identified as a gay cancer
Kaposi's sarcoma and it was a thought
that it was connected to homosexuality
somehow inherently in fact lesbians are
not allowed to give blood at the
beginning of the AIDS crisis because
they thought they would have to do with
homosexuality so no one knew how it was
transmitted or what so was totally by an
accident of history that I happened to
be on the scene as a girl reporter when
aids started and I covered a lot of
early stories that covered the closing
of the bathhouses for the New York
native the forming of the first PWA
organizations I then went on and became
an in aids reporter at the Village Voice
they were the first piece of women being
excluded from experimental drug trials I
wrote the first piece on homeless people
with AIDS that appeared anywhere which
was in the nation that was interesting
as a nation was so homophobic that the
only way they would cover AIDS was when
it affected homeless people and that's
you know it's a wanting any of people
who ignore homeless people the days at
any of people for whom it's more
acceptable than gay people at that time
and I also covered pediatric AIDS which
fortunately doesn't exist anymore for
reasons that we'll go into later which
just has to do is important part of the
history of act-up but at the time there
was a lot of pediatric AIDS
city and infants were being treated on a
placebo basis and this raised the issue
of consent what is consent which has
been a question that has pervaded
throughout the AIDS crisis and is still
very present today especially in vaccine
research which is not conducted in the
United States because we have more rigid
consent standards
so so I was on this from the very early
days and the first five years of AIDS
there were 40,000 people died of AIDS
from 81 to 86 there were no treatments
the only treatment was a recycled failed
cancer drug called AZT that cost $10,000
a year and ultimately didn't work but
people didn't realize that and then
active was founded in 1987 and I jumped
out in February I joined in July so
that's how I got to act up my
relationship to AIDS and to act up is
much like my relationship to the world
and that through the lens of a camera
really look at the world I started
filming the gay movement in the late 70s
and when when I first became aware of
AIDS in 1981 and in those few years
first few years I wanted to make a film
about it AIDS but it was I couldn't
figure out how to do it it was really
difficult in the mainstream media if
they weren't ignoring people with AIDS
they were showing them as you know these
horrible shameful victims of this
disgusting disease and you know I wasn't
gonna about to recreate that on some
grassroots level I I wanted to do
something different and I kind of found
it around looking for a subject and I
met this guy and who had AIDS and I
started filming him but it didn't last
very long because he didn't want me in
his face with a
a camera all the time so that didn't
succeed and then two things that but one
is my ex-lover Roger Jacoby was
diagnosed with the AIDS in August of
1984 and from then until his death in
November of 1985 I filmed him because he
was a filmmaker he was used to having a
camera around and also he wanted to be
done and then when he died I inherited
all his outtakes so I and he was
something of a narcissist so he filmed
himself a lot so I had had bad for and
then then suddenly in in March of 1987
act-up appeared and the there was
something that was really exciting to
film all of a sudden
so because act up with really conscious
of media and wanting to do something
that was visually interesting in order
to get people's attention so so I have
those two things I had a personal
relationship to to AIDS and the
political relationship to AIDS and I can
combine them in the film which
eventually it was finished in 1989 is
called elegy in the streets and it's a
30 minute silent self process
experimental film about about those
things the personal and political
experiences and reactions to to AIDS and
so I I first filmed act up in June of
1987 at the lesbian gay pride march that
year they had a concentration camp
because people were really afraid that
the Reagan administration was gonna
quarantine people with AIDS and then the
next thing I film was the 96 our
continuous picket of Memorial
sloan-kettering Hospital there were a
group of five to seven hospitals I
including Columbia Presbyterian that
were designated as AIDS treatment
evaluation units a teus and these
hospitals were supposed to do trials on
drugs and I don't remember the exact
numbers but say sloan-kettering this was
to get a hundred and twenty people
enrolled in a trial and you know after a
year and spending all sorts of money
they had eight people so backed up spent
ninety six hours embarrassing them and
demanding that they they get to work and
then from that on I you know like tell
them act ups demonstrations and when I
say filmed I mean film I mostly on
sixteen millimeter although at that time
there arose a movement to AIDS activist
video movement where forty sixty out it
and we don't know how many people who
had access to consumer-grade video
cameras video a camp came out in 1988 I
889 so suddenly middle class people
could afford video cameras
and and relatively high quality ones so
so there was a movement to document what
wasn't being documented by the
mainstream media and and to create
videotapes that could be sent around the
country as VHS tapes and get the vital
information that could help people
prolong their lives so and now also at
that time in 1988 I got a grant which
consisted of a video 8 camera it was my
first video camera and I said I was
going to do oral histories of act-up I
proceeded to do I did seven of them it
was ten and a half hours of footage and
the filmmaker of me who was used to
dealing with two minutes and 46 seconds
reels of 16 millimeter film looked at
ten and a half hours of footage and said
oh my god what am I going to do with
this how am I ever going to edit it and
I stopped doing it and so the act of
oral history project is at least in part
a corrective for that misunderstanding
of the value of okay so let me just tell
you a little bit about how we started
this project so joined act up that that
that was my first action sloan kettering
1987 so he remember at that point there
were no treatments by 1996 the cocktail
we call a cocktail was a combination
treatments were all were now in place so
within 10 years act up completely
revolutionized treatments and
through a lot of research and treatments
became available that's within quotation
marks if you are healthy if you have
insurance if you have a home you can get
treatment if you can tolerate the
treatment and you're HIV positive you
can live a full life in the United
States that's a lot of ifs but that's
basically what was achieved by 1996 at
that point act-up had basically de
mobilized for a lot of reasons which we
can go into later and we all went on
with our lives cut ahead
it's 2001 I'm in LA I'm driving it
around in a little white rental car I'm
listening to NPR and they're saying
today is the 20th anniversary of AIDS
that's interesting and then the the
announcer says at first America had
trouble with people with AIDS but then
they came around like I almost crashed
the car and I pulled over I remember I
had my first cell phone to do something
about this so we decided that we're
going to start this project and we began
interviewing people that we had known
and the interviews are long form they're
two to four hours each no one has ever
cut short people can talk for as long as
they wish I've conducted all but two
interviews Jim and other guy James
Wednesday or the camera guy so basically
a little mom-and-pop project and because
it's the two of us we have been able to
consistently Rican Sep xual eyes the
project I do not understand how an
outsider can conduct our
to tell you the truth and I don't
understand how real questions can drive
an oral history project both of those
things are mysterious to me because
every time I talk to somebody we're
finding out new information
we're Rican sexualizing the
understanding of the movement how it
functioned and I want and I just want to
tell you two things that we've I think
we've come to understand from from this
process of changing questions one is
that how how act-up worked that the
reason it was successful because was
that there was a simultaneity of actions
that all different kinds of people were
working on all different kinds of levels
based on where they were at and just as
a very experienced political organizer
let me tell you people can only be where
they're at so if you try to have a
movement where you're controlling
everyone and telling them what they
can't do and what they can do what they
must do where they must go it was
probably not going to work but the thing
about act-up was a true democracy and
everybody was doing what they needed to
do so if you needed to work with the
black church you work with the black
church if you need to go to Chinatown
he worked in Chinatown if you needed to
work on needle exchange that's what you
did people and because they was self
selected and it was going on
simultaneously
that's how act up was able to create
change because it was never a huge
number of people the largest
demonstration they ever had was 7,000
people surrounding Saint Patrick's
Cathedral but for the most part it was
between like four and eight hundred
people it was one of those vanguard
organizations where people were very
very focused they had very fixed agendas
they and they moved towards those
agendas so that was the first thing one
of the first things that we learned and
the second thing we learned is that it
was the opposite of Occupy Wall Street
in that act of had very specific demands
and the way it was constructed was very
stuff you read dr. King's letter from
Bernie
he lays out a strategy very similar to
act ups although we were not aware of
that we came to the same conclusions
first he calls self-education so active
became their experts on aids to the
point where active was telling science
what needed to be researched they were
telling was saying what laws needed to
be passed what insurance policies needed
to be passed we were setting an agenda
for everything that needed to change we
were the experts in every arena we would
develop the plan of how to get drugs to
people who couldn't afford them and
present those plans to the FDA and we
did all the conceptualization then we
would present a mega demand that was
reason
that's true however I'm an optimist I'll
tell you why I've gotten very involved
with the queer movement in Palestine I'm
a big advocate for Palestine and I've
been working with them for two years and
I can tell you that from what I've
observed globally there is a very
radical queer movement that is emerging
that's very tied into issues like
occupation colonialism the global South
in a way that the u.s. bushwalk peer
movement is left in the dust and that's
the movement that's rear addict alai
think so if you're looking at things
like homo nationalism do you know what
that is
homo nationalism is we're like in
countries like Holland or Germany where
white gay people pretty much have the
same rights as straight people you're
seeing a certain sector of those people
white people identifying with racist
movements that are anti-immigrant inside
their own nations because there are no
longer in contradiction for being gay
right so they're moving into their
racial position
I mean United States we don't have
rights we don't have equal rights
although Don't Ask Don't Tell is a homo
Nationalist impulse you know but the
critique of that is a global critique I
mean it's was identified by J's beer par
who's a professor at Rutgers but most of
the action around homo nationalism is
global so I mean that's where the future
of the queer movement is
learn information about epidemiology
about HIV about drugs I mean on one hand
people were living at and of course like
their bodies were very much almost like
experiments old but on the other and you
know they were formally trained so these
talk about how after death was really
kind of a group of experts can you talk
a little bit more about how do you think
that was even accomplished in the first
place
given the high barriers to knowledge
yeah yeah I think you know when you
really need to know something
like my my personal experience actually
predates aids predates actually when
when I first started processing my own
film I had to know learn about organic
chemistry so suddenly I could go into
the Carnegie Library in Pittsburgh and
read organic chemistry
you know graduate level organic
chemistry textbooks and it made sense to
me and when I you know like when I was
in high school you know I remember
learning these wrote formulas but they
couldn't understand it so when when you
sit down and learn it and what the guys
did in treatment and data committee was
they just they just first of all is much
more difficult to get the information
but they managed to by making all these
phone calls you know you just start
calling people and say you know what
what trials are going on and and so and
they would make lists of them so that
people could actually try to get into
the trials but also they were reading
these abstracts and they were sitting
there with with dictionaries and just
looking up
one word after another and you know
after a while it starts making sense to
you
and then suddenly then someone had the
idea of creating a glossary so they've
typed up a glossary and xeroxed it it
was an immense Xerox pill in in act up
and also people who worked in copy shops
who would do it for free but still you
know it's actually one of the ongoing
things about act up how much are we
spending in in Xerox so so these things
you know like people just went to school
and they they got PhDs in organic
chemistry except they don't have the
parchment
yes
the things that you were able to get
for the interview
because I'm not questioned you were in
the house but but perspectives that
if there are I don't know what they are
I mean it's interesting design it when I
first saw your first cut I realized that
you the shots you have told from act ups
point of view were like shot from inside
the demonstrations from inside the
meetings and that you were making a
descent aesthetic decision yeah I mean
that the film is is from active point of
view in fact there there's my editor at
of forced me to put in a little bit of
mass media for mainstream media so
there's like a shot of Tom Brokaw and 20
seconds of Dan Rather and two articles
from the New York Times but but you know
I don't really care about that they
weren't telling the real story anyway
the real story was
yeah
well no one said I mean I entitlement
this is something that I learned from
active entitlement allows people to
enter into institutions and believe that
they have the right to be part of them
like in 1979 when I was 21 I was in an
action called a women's action at the
Pentagon and women went and wove we wove
a web of women's rage around the
Pentagon funny we never thought about
going into the Pentagon but ACT UP would
go into the FDA or into the CDC and it's
an entirely different self perception
that you have a right to be inside the
apparatus you know it really elevates
how you imagine your task
it also rubs off you know I mean because
people who would normally not feel that
way took up took on that stance or were
capable of taking on that stance because
because of the group like for example
when the Gulf War war first started we
had this thing called the day of
desperation and a group of people
decided they were going to interrupt the
evening news so and they wanted to say
fight AIDS not Arabs so they had to get
into the Dan Rather broadcast well
someone in act up used to work at CBS
News and she drew a map for them of the
entire structure studio and gave them
her ID card which are brilliant artists
copied so they all had phony IDs and
they got in and they interrupted the
evening news but if we hadn't had
someone who knew the inside system we
wouldn't been able to get in but she
wasn't the one who went in see what I
mean yeah
I can tell what I figured out for myself
about that you could spend your whole
life trying to convince one person to
change their mind forget it you don't
need to have consensus in an
organization all you need to have is
critical mass so if you need X number of
people to run the CDC campaign for four
years that's all you know if these other
people are against you don't want to do
it forget about them people spend so
much political energy trying to force
consensus trying to force everyone to
see some things the same way to stop
people from doing things they want to do
forget about that if you believe in
something do it if somebody else wants
to do something you don't want to do let
them do it it's hard but I really think
active proves that that is the most
effective way wait and also act up
worked in very different ways I mean
there was a very large action that
involves almost everybody in the group
then there were and there were affinity
groups within act up so that those
individual affinity groups could do
certain particular things within those
actions but they could also go up and do
things on their own that the the the
large group didn't have to to support
necessarily although you know because of
the ethos of act up everything fed into
the larger whole and then there were
smaller things like zaps that somebody
somebody would come up with an idea on
on a Monday night and and ask about it
at the meeting and ten people would go
and do something on Tuesday so so there
was there's a whole range of activities
that could be supported within right now
you can't try to control other people in
that situation and nobody was trying
do that yeah
actually the only person who ever called
for that was Larry Kramer he made a
speech saying that we had to take up
arms but nobody listened to him there's
a lot of reasons why and I think they're
worth examining one is just gay people
generally I mean straight people go and
gay bash gay people right all the time
ever heard of gay people bashing a
straight person really not I mean
there's one example I can think of in
the West Village of a couple of years
ago but really for the most part gay
people don't do that so that kind of
thing is not already in the community
culture the second thing was that it's
not strategic like you can have
ideological reasons being for
non-violence but simply from a practical
point of view you can't win against the
US government if you use violence so and
then a lot of these people were sick you
know so I mean there were just a lot of
reasons not to have violence there was
violence against us one of our members
was severely brain-damaged we have
footage of the riot police just beating
the out of people I mean they it
was violence against us but we never
committed an act and you think that
people knew they were dying to the
extent that they were plotting their
political funerals and they still didn't
take anybody with them it's quite
amazing yeah
yeah
period and I've heard people say
I
but I didn't mean to imply that I felt
like you couldn't understand so if I
suddenly I believe that everyone can in
fact I mean I wouldn't wouldn't be doing
this project wouldn't be making a film
if I didn't believe that everyone is
capable of understanding this and
actually taking messages from it that go
way beyond anything that I would
particularly think of but but simply
that because you weren't around but also
that you don't have the information
about it
you don't know what's going on but but
the information has has been suppressed
I mean this is this is has been a race
from history and one of our major
impetus is behind this project is to
force the history of activism into
mainstream US history like we want to
like we think that I mean it shocks me
that US 20th century US history core
classes do not have sections on AIDS and
AIDS activism and we went to the
American Historical Association to try
to like push this into the poor
curriculum and the only people came to
our talk were gay it was so frustrating
we want all US 20th century cork I mean
how can they not discuss AIDS research
all right so we're hoping like this film
teachers will be able to show it they
won't have to learn anything they won't
have to teach it but basically I mean
the main message is that regular people
can change the world and in fact only
regular people change the world and when
you interview if you like these it's
when you go through the intervals you'll
see these are just regular people who
rose to the you know the historic
challenge and that's why it worked
yes I think it's it is ready we wanted
to propose a plan for the government so
we wanted to arrange a meeting with the
government which we had with the
eighth's are at that point in joining
over job at that point in Puerto Rico
for this I could pay for it
I took pay for it so I was you know one
of the things was that we we were like
he was calling people we knew like I
call a friend who rented condominiums
and I said could you really help me with
this and he gave us a very cheap deal
and we put everybody one in what
apartment then we will have meetings you
know in the houses of people that we
will me and Carlos will go to the bars
and because we had a history in the
community before people knew who we were
notice that capacity we would with this
silence equals death sticker the Spanish
one oh yeah we'll go with our active
outfits little short jeans and boots and
those people smile and put a sticker in
the chest and develop what's this all
you want to know I will so we'll come to
this meeting and it was it was amazing
because then the other people came the
other active members Latinos I know
they're also know Latinas members but my
memory is not that great now and they
you know we started to do the same go
out and put stickers of people and just
static emergency and then we knew some
some some owner of the bar and they of
course they were at that point people
were getting sick and dying so he opened
the bar for meetings and
and I remember like in two weeks we had
like a meeting of 200 people you know
she was for Porto Rico you know it's
like and you know it was a really rough
conversation to negotiate if they really
needed an act about chapter or they just
needed to you know start the fire and
they take it from there and we need
because we were not gonna stay but she
was my main concern you know you don't
go there and say you need to have an act
out because we were not there so that
was one of the you know I think big
things we accomplished there and we have
a series of demonstrations we have one
and the first time Sullivan was having a
meeting with the Department of Health in
front of the hotel we had like 10 20
people but we got media covering then we
had another demonstration as did the
Commission meeting and we were getting
more and he was all like in crescendo to
get to we wanted to do it March you know
in all someone and he don't you know it
all happened with we began to get more
people and more people and then you know
we had a pretty successful march in all
someone we will say their gobierno tina
sentences manos the same thing the
government has brought in their hand and
so it was pretty powerful because it was
the first time there was there was a
very activist like direct action you
know taken there so that's active and
we'll they started an active chapter of
course that I knew this it was not going
to evolve as Arthur and I think what it
did was that you know for one year to
some people kept me ninis act up but
then all
group started you know with their flavor
with their needs and and even the b-flat
chapter started you know it was for me
was more it was known about habit and
successful active chapter but was just
to you know set the fire and and I think
it started you know to extend to other
people that
yes
such an advanced ages there longer
initiative
so I can blame it on one person Andrew
Sullivan hmm yeah and just Sullivan did
a cover story in The New York Times
remember the day is at 1900 sometime in
96 95 the end of AIDS the end of AIDS
because he became undetectable so AIDS
was over right that just did so much
damage because it was just like the
poster boy for a white you know right
wing he was a Bush to Bush supporter one
point and we've been dealing with that
ever since
if you talk a little bit more about just
kind of the role of media in terms of
you know there is this criticism of
media as just giving the wrong
information and you know you saw that in
the cosmopolitan demonstration NEA
Women's Committee and you saw that with
Brokaw break in but do you think that
active kind of pioneered almost like a
hijacking the news media it's a kind of
we forced them I mean at that time not
only with the New York Times not cover
aids they wouldn't see used the word gay
and if you died and you had a partner
they weren't allowed to have one
they wouldn't mention it in the
obituaries they wouldn't say that people
died of AIDS and I remember when the New
York Times got their first fax machine
act up fax than one mile of black paper
you know and and then acted made a mock
New York Times called New York rhymes
that they went around and put in all the
boxes I mean and eventually they were
forced into cover aids that he even when
they were covering AIDS and the
reporters were just not very good there
was lots of information they would get
AP reporters there was a lot of and
Lawrence Altman and basically she just
made mishmash of science and his problem
was that he loved to take government
press releases and just the only good
aids reporter there was Linda via Rosa
do you know her she's an out lesbian she
used to be an editor at Essence magazine
she did a four-part series on the front
page of the New York Times it's that
black women in HIV it's which is in my
mind the best thing has ever been
written
she was the highest-ranking black woman
at the New York Times at that time so
her coverage was really excellent it was
a you know it's about black women being
socially coerced into unsafe sex because
of the black male shortage ever you want
to however you analyze that and you know
that's the kind of reporting that does
not appear in the New York Linda be
erosive EIL lar OSA she's currently
doing a two-part series for frontline on
the history of black people on AIDS
she's like the expert on black people on
AIDS in the United States
yeah are there any kind of
disappointments that you see kind of in
the current historical interpretation of
hiv/aids especially with kind of like
official government accounts I know the
30 year anniversary was kind of
introduced with big fanfare and events
where the things are well the thing that
I hate is that they're all using the
progress narrative which is a false
narrative and if you try to complicate
it it's not permissible it always has to
be that things get better as time passes
and you know why we have a higher
infection rate in Washington DC than in
West Africa I would like to know the
answer to that but that's that is an
indication that we don't have a progress
narrative going on and also they take
credit for what the things that they
were forced into yeah you know you know
is that of the goodness of their hearts
that they start doing all this research
we spoke at the NIH this was so crazy we
had gone to the demonstration at the NIH
where our friends were now dead we got
arrested and hauled off to jail and then
years later and then you know when
people were arrested with police wearing
yellow rubber gloves I mean so insanely
demeaning years later Jim and I were
invited to give a talk at the NIH and we
went in we walked right in this time we
gave her demonstration and after
everyone left I ran outside and
collected all the memorabilia and put it
in our collection but isn't it wonderful
that dr. faoud she had the visionary
insight to realize that everyone needed
to have a seat at the table you're like
wow that is not what happened
you know these people are friends we
could tell you their names they died
forcing you to let us have a seat at the
table
you know niggas anyone she watched out
the window she couldn't remember what it
really had this is just a lack of
accountability
yes
if we do mobilization of champ Oh champ
and there
she's campaign
I'm really not a big fan of champ so
maybe I shouldn't want to go inside no
and then second my second question was
down and well compute it
it's an activist of existence in Paris
in New York you know yeah
there were 140 chapters that arose
spontaneously in the late 80s three or
four
well it's partially which him was saying
that the camcorder got invented in the
middle of act up so act up in a sense
invented video activist so that I mean
the whole YouTube phenomena they're
really the precursor to that because act
up we had a variety of different video
teams and collectives they would shoot
the tape and then they would bring the
tape to the television stations so we
were really producing our own media at
you know very early on in the
development of video the other thing is
we were very media savvy we had people
Mike senior rally who ran the media
committee had come from People magazine
we had people who came from very high
levels of like I said CBS and all this
kind of stuff so like we would time
demonstrations for live feeds for the
Evening News for example things like
that you know they were just very smart
about that Jim shows in the film that at
the first at the action at the Food and
Drug Administration the National Trust
came for the first time to an active
demonstration and we already had people
with AIDS from cities all over the
country many of them were very ill in
wheelchairs etc
sitting there saying what city they were
from so that their national their press
could come and interview them we
constructed that for the media to
facilitate coverage wait and actually it
started earlier than that I remember the
Colangelo story about how in preparation
for the FDA demonstration has got chip
duckin who yeah his job had been
arranging cookbook tours so people who
wrote cookbooks would go on these tours
and and they would set up interviews in
all these cities and towns across the
United States on the little TV programs
or radio programs so he knew this
circuit and what he did is he recruited
people all around the country and they
did these trainings over the phone and
they had the whole press packet that all
these people had so there was always it
work done before the demonstration to
get keep get the reporters to rockville
maryland and interested already
interested in men there with people who
satisfy that interest but to go back to
your question that how i act up used
media there were several things one is
okay so there are all these people
videotaping and they were organized into
several collectives one testing the
limits was a group about six people they
made a tape called testing the limits
which is where their name came from and
then voices from the front which is what
made it 92 and kind of overview of the
movement up until then then there was a
much larger group called diva TV damned
interfering video activist television
and there there was a core group of 10
or 12 but as many as 40 people
videotaped four or diva TV and and they
made finished tapes and the tapes were
designed for people to show in meetings
and they sent them all around the
country and people show it to their
friends and their colleagues and
neighbors and in these little meetings
but also they would document they were
focused on the police to keep the police
in line and in cases where people were
charged with crimes that they didn't
commit
it was videotape to prove that they
hadn't hadn't done what they were being
charged with so there were lots of uses
of video
daddy how part was public access oh
right yeah right there was public access
into public access well public acts was
started in the 70s act first AIDS
related program was the GMHC living with
AIDS program and that started thinking
87 and that was won by Jean Carlo Musco
and of people act up they had two
programs there was aids community
television which James when he started
he's our he's our camera person he
essentially made a hundred and fifty
half an hour programs all by himself I
mean he would film it edit it and you
know I can show it within a week I mean
he had we would have people helping
helping him from time to time but
largely it was a solo effort and then
there was an act up live program what
people would sit around and just answer
people call in and ask questions and
answer certain things prepared but but
that went on for several years so there
was this cable access yes that house of
kolor and grand fury those were two are
groups inside act up basically affinity
groups for like twenty to thirty people
so there were you consider there were
four to eight hundred people and act up
there were many many many affinity
groups and some of them were art related
or media related and it's all
interconnected like house of caller some
of the people were doing house of kolor
were also running of this big lesbian
bar called the clique club on the which
was the first interracial as being bar
in New York City
those were the same activists who were
doing house of kolor so there was a big
crossover between who was doing work
inside act
and the community the culture in the
community citywide it was not isolated
at all it's very integrated yes we had a
phone tree
phone tree was each person had like 20
names they had to call so you would get
your call
and then you would call your 20 names
and tell them whatever the message was
right I think that's one of the reasons
why they're the Monday night meetings
you know so crucial because that way
everybody can get together people could
talk to each other but the information
could be you know disseminated that way
that there were always reports from
committees and from from affinity groups
and there was a table in the back of
actually two tables each about the size
of this one here completely covered with
stacks of paper with all sorts of
information on all aspects of the AIDS
movement so in everything every week
you'd come in and you know like you'd go
down the table and you pick everything
up like you'd have the stack of paper to
go home because not only was it before
the internet it was before answering
machines
the person until somebody would answer
yeah
all right just
I have a very favorable view of that
occupy wallstreet I think it's fantastic
and amazing and I'm so glad that it's
happening at the same time I thinking I
had also where is it going I have
concerns about that but you know it's a
very American tradition this type of
movement I mean they were utopian
socialists in the 19th century and they
were anarchists in the 20th 1920s and
they had be movement and the sixties
these kind of spiritual total
transformation movements it's a very
American thing and they often create
other movements that have very set
agendas and are able to actually achieve
change however they also can be easily
co-opted they can dissipate and they
also can be victimized by police
violence and that's one of my very big
concerns for this movement because you
know I I remember like Kent State and
Jackson State and these types of events
and you know I don't know where it's
going so right now I love it
I hope it gets an agenda really soon of
something of course once you force
something you lose support because it's
very easy to support a generic movement
right once they actually say what they
want they're gonna lose some kind of
support and that's scary but ultimately
if you want to create change you have to
you can't just exist parallel to all the
institutions you oppose at some point
you have to approach them and confront
them on some on some grounds
that's basically my position but I'm
also you know in the ironic position
that I am completely focused on and
concentrating on making this bill about
activism in an office two blocks from
and I've hardly been there you know I
you know every once in awhile I just
like to force myself to get up and walk
over there it's really I think it's
really great and it's because if you
don't watch TV then you have what you
hear things by word of mouth and their
word of mouth is not conveying Occupy
Wall Street people they talk to everyday
or not talking about it because I
brought it up in class like a month ago
and about half my students had never
heard of it so the class divide is a big
except they're very much on the that
side of the class divide yes they're not
in the 99 I mean 99% is a very category
because you start standing for something
you're going to lose a lot of that yes
I wanted to ask you some some folks over
with are trying to do a pending
treatment waiting list
no that's that's the big issue isn't it
the waiting lists were for I know that
is huge and our president has lied to us
about what he was going to yeah that is
HUGE
is there a way to make the Democratic
Party accountable for their promises to
people with days that's the question
that you're asking I don't know you
enchant is that the good
not in Chicago but in so many different
states
I don't know people are well women with
AIDS are in the category for people with
a s I mean ya know that is the most
pressing issue for people with AIDS
right now is those waiting list that's
right
any other thoughts questions
yes did you encounter issues oh well you
mean originally when I created the
collection for the New York Public
Library or well okay well I first
started putting that collection together
in 1995 and you know I just called up
people and said you know that this the
library wanted wanted to collect the
material and they would it was money to
store it properly and also to remaster
it so so you know the material would
have a life after it and some people
were just ecstatic and they said here
you know it's been sitting in my closet
it's been sitting under my bed please
take it and and there are some people
who are you know where where they're
like someone said to me well if I give
them up my material that means I'm kind
of guy you know what do you see what he
say to that and then and then in one
case ray Navarro died in his his mother
had had his material for years and years
them so I went out to visit her and Simi
Valley California and was in her living
room and she had taken all of raised
Apes and spreaded the living and it was
like you know like Ray's body was
sitting lying there and so I tried like
I bought her boxes and I tried to get
her to pack it up but she just she just
couldn't do it and in fact she just
recently there are other films being
made
when I'm David Francis she actually sent
all the material to him
so this that's how many elite years
later it's 15 years later she found me
can can deal with it the testing the
limits people there are six people who
you know well some of them talk to each
other but not all six couldn't possibly
get into a room for years and years in
fact the reason that their material
isn't when you know Public Library was
that it was in storage and they could no
longer pay for the storage so the
library just paid the past due rent and
took the material and in fifteen years
they still haven't signed the agreement
the library just acts as if they had but
so they were for years they were
incredibly protective of the material
but in the last couple years as I called
them up and said can I get these tapes I
mean I have to list every tape I want
and get permission from the copyright
owner because the library doesn't just
owns the physical object you know
suddenly it became really because people
are realizing they you know they did
this incredible thing twenty-five years
ago and it what's important is that the
material gave used and gets shown and in
whatever different ways so so people
have evolving feelings and attitudes
towards towards the material
I will say that there's been nothing but
appreciation from the act-up community
towards Jim and I for doing this project
nobody contested our right to do it
everyone was relieved because nobody
else wanted to do it and last summer I
did a screening for some old active
people in LA and they really loved the
film which was a great relief to us so
there's been no problems in that regard
yeah
shortly
going back
we have different reaction yeah you know
um you know I sit at a desk in a
computer and watch the stuff over and
over again and yeah it's very emotional
experience and but at the same time also
in this footage my friends are still
alive
so so I feel like I'm I as a person who
survived this I have this responsibility
to to those people who died and that you
know that's one of the reasons why I'm
making them
I just feel upset and the fact that
these people are forgotten I mean
they're Pete there's still this one guy
we can't find him Rick yeah I mean like
we had this food we only just figured we
had the wrong name and then we figured
out the right name and no one knows
where he is and he's not on Facebook and
you can't google him which is usually
bad news right but I don't want to say
that he's dead because I don't know that
and maybe he's incarcerated I don't know
where he is and we've got this place and
it's like it's so difficult all these
great people they're gone gone gone gone
nobody remembers them if they made it
into the cut then their name is up there
and if they didn't they're gone you know
we just look at footage saying who's
that who's that what's his name he looks
familiar I remember him was that a lot
of people are completely forgotten white
people were driven out of their families
they were driven out of their
small towns they came here they had a
gay life they died at 25 you know
there's no there's no record of them
80,000 people died in New York City of
AIDS
compare that to 9/11 right and 9/11 all
those 3,000 people are individuated
every year their names are read these
80,000 people who knows who they were
it's like they never lived you know so
that's what I get
watch it it's upsetting every single
time I've seen this some 40 times
yes
so yeah I don't know yeah I don't I
don't understand that concept I just I
mean we're dude we're doing our
responsibilities right so I'm not proud
of
I mean they're people with interviewed
who have not talked about it since it
happened there's a lot of us you know
there's a lot of people walking around
who had people that they were very close
to who died tragically and horribly in
front of their eyes that all the people
they know now don't even know that they
went through that it's a it's an
undiscussed experience of the past I
mean if you any gay man you know is over
a certain age you know that they lived
through that I mean so it's very
invisible a nationwide five hundred
thousand people died of AIDS the United
States this is never a Morial or
anything like that it's very very
invisible so there's a trauma there you
know Jim was saying earlier that the
whole gay marriage thing in a way is
response to that trauma to the to the
AIDS trauma you know and it hasn't been
articulated I have a book coming out in
February it's called the gentrification
of the moing that's about the confluence
of AIDS and gentrification and how it's
changed the way we think and how it's
changed what our vanity is and so I'm
trying to say what are the consequences
of AIDS because that's the question
that's not being asked and I don't buy
that I don't mean to imply that AIDS has
ended because there's two AIDS right
there's ongoing AIDS and then there's
AIDS of the past and they're two
different phenomena but AIDS of the past
has incredible consequences because I
mean when you're someone like us you
walk around the world you see all the
holes where all the people aren't but
other people don't see that so I see all
the absence but you don't see you don't
see so I see who's not running
organizations who didn't become a
professor who's not influencing things
because they died at 25 and aware of
that but obviously you can't be aware of
that
that's the difference it's a different
experience also like I said you know I
come from uh it's because you know like
I said we're both Jewish and we post
fall across people and so there's a
certain kind of consciousness about that
about the necess and SS 'ti of telling
certain stories and also later of not
letting those stories being co-opted for
for negative agendas either you know of
being being truthful about these events
and seeing how they really what their
consequences really are I'm very I was
raised with that I'm very invested
okay